da bin ich noch in hamburg ging da bin
ich noch in hamburg - 10 von 10 - 10 von
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die zeit ist gekommen die zeit ist
gekommen dass ich ehrlich mal wieder
meiner besten freundin auf youtube einen
kleinen besuch abstatte denn viele von
euch haben sich unter anderem auf
install um darauf hingewiesen dass sich
einfach nichts verändert hat dass man
jetzt ein video also hier wartet auf
mich dass andere sagen es geht hat das
und was gesagt hat dann lasse ich mal
lieber aber es geht mir nicht in den
kopf rein
diese habe immer noch so weitergeht wie
vorher ein paar von euch kann sich schon
jetzt schon denken um wen und um was es
geht ich sag's trotzdem noch mal es geht
um mobbing und diesen gottverdammten
game master müll mein erstes video zu
diesem unsinn ist keine ahnung wie lange
her
zwei drei vier wochen vielleicht sogar
schon monat und es war muss ich zugeben
ich hier zu sehen hat es immer wieder
auch in karlstadt habt dass sie das
scheinbar immer noch macht und dass
leute immer noch sich denken einfach
geil also leute lange nicht angekommen
ihr wisst licher pistenspaß dabei nicht
über dinge lustig zu machen also aber
doch an damit ganz kurz zuvor hatte noch
ein kurzes schaut anteil an die einfach
bis vor kurzem ein video hatte hieß so
kay master natürlich ohne kondom
geht's noch
aber fangen wir an leute das video um
das es bei rebecca hingeht ist auch im
kanal trailer und heißt im auto bild von
game master 24 stunden entführt käme
aufgrund bekannten raum gesperrt yoda
wäre stolz
an der stelle muss ich etwas gestehen
leute ich habe tatsächlich nicht alle
game master videos von rektorin geschaut
wie versteht sicherlich ich hatte doch
noch ein interesse daran meine geistige
gesundheit und mein leben zu behalten
ihre videos ball immer aufeinander auf
und schauen was hier jetzt beim game
master ins auto eingestiegen das alleine
ist schon wieder genug um sie als
zuschauer hier einfach mal komplett die
kugel zu geben weil das was von sinn
macht das fest steigt bei einer fremden
person die game master ist ins auto wenn
ich der ansicht dass gerade fragt wie so
eine szene zustande kommt halt dort
leute
wieso sitzt sie mit einer schlafbrille
auf dem rücksitz von dem auto die so wie
kommt man als manager solle situation
ist jetzt stark sein leute ihr müsst
jetzt wirklich stark sein ich weiß
gehirn will den dienst an dieser stelle
schon beenden aber wir sind gerade erst
30 sekunden in diesem video drin
ihr müsst noch durchhalten gebt nicht
auf selbstverständliches trading vom
game master entführt worden
klar ist wer es noch nicht vom game
master entführt worden wurde dann
selbstverständlich hat irgendein ort
gebracht und an diesem ort liegt
wahnsinn hat der liegt ihre kamera für
die körper der kamera perfekt so in
welcher ecke der welt ist das entstanden
weil in der gegend in der ich wohne von
dem ich deutschland nordrhein-westfalen
liegen nicht einfach kameras in
irgendwelchen rollen rum wo
passenderweise auch eine speicherkarte
drin ist und sie sind geladen so nach
dem motto ach vielleicht lege meine
kamera
könnte ja sein dass irgendwie youtube
vom game master enthüllt wird und
hierhin gebracht wird
allein da muss man doch schon aussteigen
oder also für welches menschliche gehirn
macht so etwas in die jahre kommen ich
bin gleich ihr wach geworden sich das
hier weg doch diese schlafmaske dich
drauf tun sollte im auto aber ich bin
ich hier hin gekommen
es tut schon weh das tut schon weh sich
das anzuschauen
ich will ein erstes mal nicht
rausschicken alle die unter diesem jetzt
in den kommentaren sind oder schon
kommentar geschrieben haben beck ist die
geilste du bist man neidisch das was sie
da macht ist nicht fällig will euch
wirklich gerne verstehen schreibt mal
bitte in die kommentare
was ihr an diesem videos gut findet
denkt ihr diesen echt denke das ist
alles echt und es gibt den game master
wirklich oder wisst ihr das alles
gefecht ist und dass sie trotzdem hätte
ich persönlich bin ein bisschen ratlos
ich sehe dieses video und sehe dass es
52.000 likes 1600 displays hat und ich
frage mich wirklich ein feines sind die
leute einfach zu blöd oder es ist ihnen
egal ich weiß nur ich bin jetzt im auto
gewesen ich habe den komischen seltsam
autoschlüssel vor der haustür gefunden
der hat mich zu so einem auto geführt
dann bin ich eingestiegen und der meinte
gay machst du über die apple board habe
ich auch noch um habt ihr mittlerweile
auch apple bot schon game master
bekommen
wie gesagt ich hoffe rebecca dass du die
sachen nicht von der steuer absetzt für
uns alle die deutschen steuern zahlen
oder deren eltern steuern zahlen wie
normale menschen bitte sagt dass du
nicht weniger steuern zeit weil du dir
irgendwelche sachen für game master
videos kaufst wie man will das hinführen
sowas kann man sich so game master
zwingt mich porsche zu kaufen game
master sperrt mich in louis vuitton
boutique ein und ich muss zähler schon
kaufen ist ja nicht für mich
the game master game master trinken wir
das ja auch genau dass ich irgendwie
meine auch verbinden soll da habe ich
das drauf gemacht und dann stieg
irgendjemand ein und ist losgefahren
danach habe ich keine ahnung bin ich
eingeschlafen
nicht verstehe es nicht leute also
selbst wenn man glaubt das ist wirklich
ein game master gibt dann erst mal mein
beileid aber danach trotzdem dass es
einfach so schlecht geschauspielert ist
machen die die zuschauer nicht genug
menschenkenntnis und zu erkennen dass
das einfach mal komplett ausgedacht ist
ich habe mittlerweile wirklich ein
echtes interesse an zu verstehen was da
passiert ist bin ich was mache ich hier
das ist irgendwie ein hotelzimmer alles
klar
kurz ausdrücken die kommentare leute
weil wenn ich so die kommentare schaue
dann entwickelt sich so in mir die idee
und besteht sich die idee dass die leute
ist wirklich einfach nicht kennen
die checken nicht dass das fake ist weil
hier gibt es kommentare wie das ist so
spannend wie ich möchte dir am liebsten
helfen schwarzes herz kleeblatt hallo
wiki zwei tage nichts
80.000 traurig smile ist wo hast du
eigentlich die zeit das video zu
schneiden oder drehen da ist tatsächlich
schon so der erste funke der erkenntnis
gesehen wenn man das gerät hat er ein
bisschen hoffnung
die wird auch ein komplett zerstört oder
nächsten kommentar der woche lag damit
sie versteht mich nicht falsch heute ich
bin kein messias mit meinem
youtube-kanal solche viel action und
sagen meint ihr vieh war ja wenigstens
nicht sondern regen für mich jetzt hat
wusste ich mache das gerne aber sieht
man hierbei nicht so ein bisschen die
hoffnung in die menschheit also da
hinten liegt meine tasche
da habe ich schon gesehen da liegt
irgendwie sowas ist das schnarchen
das sind stoffe wie soll ich deine
kommentare es ist eine schroffe und da
hinten in den neoprenanzug aber der ist
nicht von mir
was soll ich damit das sind immer
kranker mann das gegeben hast du gemacht
wie alt ist
eigentlich war ich habe es gemacht und
scheinbar war sie 2000 17 24 das heißt
sie ist jetzt 25 26 und mir stellt sich
nur die frage kommt man sich
blöd vor dabei die frage stelle ich mir
teilweise selbst war ja blöd in meinen
videos bekommen
aber berlin ist drei jahre älter und
kann mir das jemand erklären die ich
hergekommen bin
wir werden jetzt auf jeden fall mal am
fenster gucken vielleicht kann man eben
was erkennen das scheint ein relativ
großes seien irgendwie wir dürfen nicht
vergessen sollte diese storyline in
diesem video ist immer noch sehr genau
das gefunden ist ein auto eingestiegen
mit schlafbrille natürlich und dann
wacht sie irgendwo zimmer auf und der
zuschauer soll glauben dass in diesem
hotelzimmer zufällig der kamera liegt
das hotel smi merkwürdig leute also ich
verstehe gar nichts mehr
also mal sind wir schon mal zwei das ist
doch recht kalt oder also ich bin jetzt
vollkommen ehrlich ich hab es kann eben
schon mal gesagt ich bin jetzt 23 und
teilweise sehe ich meine eigenen videos
und denke mir so okay das ist jetzt
nicht die allerhöchste kunst okay aber
unterhaltung aber wedding ist 25 26
scheinbar und dass das ist hier keine
ich will niemandem was vor stein
versteht mich nicht falsch aber aber ich
hätte gerne mit rebecca reden um mit ihr
darüber reden ob sie das selbst komisch
findet was sie da macht oder das für sie
voll nochmal alles ich sollte mir erst
mal schauen wo wir hier sind bin ich
noch in hamburg die da bin ich noch in
hamburg - 10 von 10 - 10 von 10
und das noch nicht gemeint ich muss mir
noch mal eben die aufnahme angucken wie
ich ja zuletzt aufgenommen habe warte
dies hier auf der kamera deswegen sehen
wir uns gleich noch mal bin ich zu alt
für solche videos heute kann man sich
die videos nur geben bis man 13 last
oder so ich denke ich so viele
kommentare von euch diese seien so ja
ich habe früher bekkering schaut als elf
war mittlerweile täglich hat das ist
bullshit ist so was so das
durchschnittsalter auf diesem kanal 3
ist irgendwie das bettchen lag dich halt
gelegt einfach mal meine tasche hier ist
ein schnorchel oder was ist das ich
hoffe immer noch es gibt noch ein
bisschen vor wenn auch der meinung seid
er meint
polier macht man jetzt den daumen nach
oben wenn ihr der meinung seid ich soll
irgendwie nach einem schatz zu suchen
okay es muss sich schon mal ein schatz
im pool suchen also ich hab da einfach
zwölf minuten video weitsprung und das
fiktive story mäßig einfach gar nichts
so der schnorchel war von anfang an da
der woche soll jetzt muss ich an meinem
pool im hotelpool schatzsuchen ist die
die jugend die das schaut die zukunft
von deutschland misst und dann am ende
irgendwie im pool und ich sie am rand
schon wieder etwa ist das hört einfach
nicht auf nötig das nächste video
scheinbar suche pool schatz vom game
master mit tauchen unter wasser kann
abfließen theorie von mir leute
rubacuori macht diese serie denkt sich
wahrscheinlich selbst so misst was
meister so power trading konnte selbst
nicht so ganz zieht aber durch weil es
eben mega erfolgreiches mega viele
klicks bringt macht urlaub in paar
schönen hotels mit ordentlichen puls
kauft sich eine apple watchers selbst
das ganze wahrscheinlich von der steuer
ab er werde bleiben wir übrig als heute
die sehen wie absurd das ist ein
gedanken weiter denken das hinterfragen
aber eben auch erkennen müssen solange
es achtjährige in deutschland gibt wird
rebecca unten weiter klickst ziehen das
war so weit von diesem video leute
erleuchtet gerne den einen oder anderen
hardcore wie kiefern in den kommentaren
sollte der ein oder andere hält
kommentar sich hier einschleichen check
getrieben ein für euch vorschlagen das
video ab das haus heute von mir ich mag
meine mama die schädeldecke ein macht's
gut